hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is pod sessions pretty much my
favorite pillar type that I've created
in last year or two but I don't get to
do often because you know first I like
mixing up the the guests I have the
format if you're listening or watching
for the first time as three guests and I
and we just kind of shoot the [ __ ]
talked about different stuff people that
I have contexts for either I'm watching
very carefully from afar or actually
know all three here I actually know
pretty well too I've met several times
in person and one I've I've interacted
with you the most actually but we
haven't met and I'm glad we finally did
that and so I'm gonna let them introduce
themselves 1-minute bio stories who they
are what they do and maybe a little fun
fact and then we're gonna get into the
show and I'm going to talk about some
topics and then also interject my
context of why I love them or admire
them or curious about them or maybe
dislike them I might be somebody who
knows but why don't we start with the
lady to my left first all right
I'm Erika Nardini I'm the CEO of
barstool sports I've been at bar stool
for two years we've taken the company
from 12 people and very small investment
to over a hundred million dollar
valuation and we're becoming a
juggernaut in the Menten space prior to
that I had a company called back stage
where I really sought to connect music
artists and their fans directly I hate
disintermediation and I thought that
artists should be able to own their data
connect with their fans have an LTV type
relationship and ultimately for all the
kids yeah yeah and ultimately to be able
to know your fans and connect with them
directly which is something I've always
been really passionate about was this
CMO of AOL worked at a bunch of big
digital media companies started my
career thinking I was going to be a
lawyer which definitely did not happen
everything when people when you tell
people you're the CEO of bar stool which
is known for not only being a young male
Yant but like edgy yeah like it's like
the only thing out there that I feel
like oh I could like that that's like
it's it's real edgy yeah like our pet or
like get the [ __ ] out of here when you
say do some people shopping like if
you're just hanging out and like real
life do some people actually think
you're joking and making a joke and or
like no really but what yeah
I didn't know you and know how bad like
really know how badass you are but also
just know that you were and I was like
at a dinner conference and everyone went
around yeah I'd be like oh those that's
funny yeah I I think I'm the curiosity
in the whole mix of it because people
wouldn't expect a woman to be a CEO of
arsal I love Barcelona proud to work
there was a huge fan of our school built
a lot of backstage based on bars because
you know because you know the
underlining truth not the not be kind of
like the the makeup that people get a
play other side curses are is raunchy I
think we live in an outraged society I
think the pressure to be PC is whelming
overwhelmed yeah and stress it's
strangling understood and the judgment
that comes with that is punitive and we
are an agenda less brand that just cares
about making its audience laughs and we
intimately get that audience so yes
that's what I love about it thank you go
ahead my man
my name is Ricci I do you think it's
funny that I always say resi no it's
always you said you were a poor student
so like he's right by the way I don't if
you saw this yesterday put out a piece
of content oh did I didn't put out on my
Instagram yet the I suck video I made a
video in 2008 that said I suck and one
of the examples of me saying that I suck
is I suck at pronounciating and saying
things the right way is in the wine
world when I was doing my lobby TV I
would get these hate emails from Italy
and be like it's but Allah not Borella
like people get so pissed at me right
and literally I haven't had that feeling
for years until I started giving you
DAPs
I'm in the wrong pronunciation so
apparently knowing that two vowels
followed by a consonant is a long vowel
doesn't really matter and you ready for
this I've never heard is that true yeah
I've never heard that he's always long
when followed by a consonant yeah I
don't even know what a [ __ ] consonant
is it's a non non vowel anyways yeah go
by Reesie
I grew up super poor food stamps welfare
government health care I never knew
anyone that owned a business had a nice
car no one in my family graduated high
school owned a house nothing I was
homeless I lived in hotels I dropped out
of high school in tenth grade had a kid
got married when I was 16 still may
eighteen years later let's go 13 years
ago I found out about selling books on
Amazon and within a year somebody said
something saying I was always I was
already into eBay because they were
running commercials one on TV when I was
like 14 so I sold everything I could
yeah and I was an avid reader one day I
sold my Star Wars books that I read and
they went for I start him for a penny
and they went for like 80% of the retail
value which blew my mind later on in
life I seen I was in thrift stores I
seen people with barcode scanner
scanning books I would ask him what are
they doing they would clam up and they
would like ignore like act like I was
invisible imagine an adult acting like
you're invisible so I was like oh
they're they're making a lot of [ __ ]
money
and I'm technology minded they had
Sarkozy others that's called street
smarts like some of the things they
don't teach you in school is when
somebody clams up it's because they're
making a lot of money right go my man so
they had they had a barcode scanner and
I was like oh those are you know at
least a hundred to three hundred bucks
so they got to be making some money so I
like drilled into it YouTube wasn't yes
because that just makes me smile to you
like just thinking about your psychology
at that point be like yo they're really
on because they got that far that's
amazing keep going so smart phones
weren't out yet iPhone wasn't out yes
wasn't out yet there was no resells
there's no books I could read you know I
exhausted my google food trying to
figure out what it was and I couldn't
figure out how they were doing the books
eventually I just kept asking every
person I went to you finally some old
lady she just told you told me
everything right away and I was like
thank you I ran home looked it all up
and then it started selling books the
next day apparently they were selling on
Amazon I didn't even know what Amazon
was at the time this was fourteen years
ago and so been selling books and other
things on Amazon full time for the last
13 years and I sold over five million
gross in that time period
about three years ago I found a little
green in black book called crush it when
I was scanning books to sell and I
scanned it it wasn't worth anything
but something about it just intrigued me
it's like it reminded me of money it's
called crush it like what like doosh
names their book crush it and then I had
just read the the delivering happiness
book the Zappos book and he has a quote
on the back of the book or whatever so
that sold me I went home opened it read
the whole thing like I just sat down and
read the whole thing and that's that's
how I learned who you were and I was
like holy [ __ ] I've been doing social
media I was like that guy that would
like post pictures of his dinner and get
like 13 likes and be like yeah killing
it like and then I was like wait a
minute like I've been using it like a TV
and now I can like push messages out and
like everything the whole if you guys
haven't read crush it that's the [ __ ]
blueprint right it's like how can you
what do you want to do how can you bring
people around you like what you know
bring all your boys to the yard or
whatever and I was like [ __ ] I know how
to sell [ __ ] and before that I was like
13 years of radio silence I didn't tell
nobody [ __ ] I was climbing up on people
and as soon as I started sharing I
started making more money people are
like oh Reesie
how come you how come you don't go there
how come you don't go to the factory
outlet and sell Nikes on Amazon and I
was like you could sell Nikes on psycho
leave they're like how come you don't
sell DVDs I was like you could sell DVDs
like I was sleazy murder what are people
gonna realize doing the right thing is
the right thing never uh I don't know
it's hard for like for me I grew up in a
really selfish family not religious like
just super selfish and then through
following your blueprint and helping
other people which totally started out
as a selfish thing in the beginning I
wanted to be a youtuber I wanted to get
my moment or whatever people start
texting me hey we're in Disneyland right
now with the family and I never thought
I would be able to take my kids to
Disneyland but because of what you did
and were able to have nice things now or
you know my husband lost his job they
can demand our family's thriving because
of your free content that you put out
helped us to achieve stuff and I get
messages like that every day and like
you said it's well you say what do you
say it's like oxygen I say it's like a
crack not nothing I know what crack is
but like I mean like I'm never
experiencing but you know what I mean
it's like intense right it's like if
there's nothing more in a high and
and do you know what happens if you take
too much oxygen that's a high yeah so
and then just real quick to wrap it up
when your team when you started the 2017
flip channel that's right because I
stopped watching your content a long
time ago like as you instructed me right
you get me sometimes on Instagram and
Facebook with the short form but I could
still sneak in once in a while right
when the 2017 flip challenge started my
phone started blowing up and like all my
boys were texting me like bro he put you
on and I'm like what and cuz you had
mentioned me before but this was like
you guys had clips from my snapchat on
there and I was like holy [ __ ] that's
two months ago so someone at Vayner was
watching my snap not so much a guy it
was you don't worry I'm always watching
what's happening
I don't watch anything I'm watching
react I don't consume any bar stool this
is real none I've never consumed any of
Pat McAfee Kev's none but I know bar
stools the most important thing going on
in sports right cuz I consume people
yeah I've never consumed a single thing
of yours right I've consumed people
taking a screenshot of your YouTube with
[ __ ] you with boxes what I know about
you visually is like boxes in the
background of your garage cuz it was a
still shot of somebody being like yo
this Gary you like flipping stuff on
garage sales this kind of like slipping
stuff you know what I mean and then you
eat you were emailing me like hey crush
it help it was very nice and I read all
my comments and i read culture thus i
can put two two together so when i
decided to do it because i you know the
reason that happened was because a
Breakfast Club I went to Breakfast Club
the first time I'm doing my thing
and DJ and he's like yo this is all fun
motivational guy you know Charlamagne
was like Gary B's the ship Envy at that
point was like you know prove it to me
he's like so give us a real piece of ice
for the people listening and you went on
the dollar train I will always go to if
I every time people asked me what would
happen if I would lose it all I go right
back to the Dollar Tree garage sales
goodwill these I can go from zero to a
million in cash if I got dropped in if
my face fell off my body like that
Travolta Nicolas Cage right and now I'm
like you know a Latino
tomorrow you can go zero to a million
easy because the high I get do you know
I found this Thundercat at a garage sale
on Saturday a year ago at 12:45 p.m. of
a garage sale
dammit Abel there is not even for a
dollar they weren't sleeping everyone
was sleeping
this shit's supposed to sell 6:00 in the
morning it's on a table for a dollar at
a garage sale like when you know you
know is it original of course it's
original damn those are the toys you had
that's right yeah I don't know I know
80s toys and I know like Rainbow Brite
and [ __ ] oh yeah my my little ponies
like I'll tell you the name of the
[ __ ] teenager I'm [ __ ] dee dee
yeah so anyway so that's why so yeah
elbows on when you started yeah 2017 yep
flip challenge yeah that kind of like I
was like oh he's talking about my [ __ ]
now like now I can really like get in
the comments like help people but right
before the 2017 flip challenge what kind
of really started our our love affair
was well you were live-streaming to a
tower livestreams right and you showed
there was you were streaming on three
platforms to periscope yep Facebook and
meerkat yes just dead now yes I couldn't
get on periscope yep I couldn't get on
Facebook that would literally you won
wouldn't let me on the other one
wouldn't let me comment and all I wanted
to do was comment and so I took the
third door I went on meerkat and then I
had my comment ready to paste and I was
just waiting it waiting and waiting and
there was like this lull where you like
the screen and I was like boom posted it
and then you read it and it was it was
like all out loud and you like had a
good reaction and then I ripped it off
of Paris or off of meerkat and I asked
you if I could use it for my youtube
intro and I'm glad you're here oh my
name is Alex
I wrote the third door and it's about my
journey the past seven years tracking
down some of the world's most successful
people figuring out how they launch
their career so you know tracking down
for business Bill Gates music Lady
Gaga's science jane goodall Maya Angelou
you know Jessica Alba Larry King Quincy
Jones Steve Wozniak and it's been this
wild adventure and a fun fact which Gary
knows is the whole journey started
when I was trying to fund the adventure
I was 18 years old I was buried in
student loan debt I was all out of our
Mitzvah cash so there had to be a way to
make some quick money and yeah when that
Bar Mitzvah cash goes yo you dress well
your backs up against the wall when you
have a dream and you have a Bar Mitzvah
cash it sounds like what am I gonna do
to make some quick money and I had this
dream and I was on Facebook the night
before final exams and I saw someone
posting free tickets the prices right
and this is crazy
keep going you know my first thought was
well what if I go on the show and win
some money to fund the dream you know I
had a problem I never seen a full
episode of the show before plus I had
finals in two days so I told myself not
to do it because as if you know someone
that pulled you know a rope around my
gut and was pulling in a direction so
that night I decided to do the logical
thing and pull an all-nighter to study
but didn't study for finals I said how
to hack the prices right and I want him
to show the next day and did this
ridiculous strategy and ended up winning
the whole showcase showdown winning a
sailboat selling the sailboat and that's
I funded the book one more time
put that last eight seconds one more
time so I pulled in on that or studied
how the show worked went the next day
won a sailboat sold the sailboat and
that's I funded the book what was the
insight that yeah it was the hacker all
right so this is how the pressure I
works they make it look random like Gary
come on down as if they pulled your name
out of a hat right yeah what I learned
during my all-nighter of research is
that there's 300 people in the audience
eight get called down one wins so the
odds the hard odds are getting from 300
to the 8 yeah
once you're one of the eight I figured I
could just wing it from there and I
realize there's a producer who
interviews every single person the
audience before the show goes on and
then there's an undercover producer
who's planted in the audience who
confirm or denies the original producer
selection so amazing it was this wild
experience and my hacking was less
Einstein and more Forrest Gump but it
worked really what I want they want
someone who is just 100 percent in okay
they want a little Gary's like oh yeah
this is why I always get picked like
maybe think of the Daily Show's first
season and I took my friend Tokyo Joe
Joe médicale who I reference a bunch
from college he's like a huge fan this
is where right out of college this is
literally like one of the only days I
did not work in my 20s this is true cuz
he came I loved him so much
we're gonna go see John Stewart I'm like
whatever uh he Joe wants to be an improv
actor it's why I moved to Chicago he's
gonna be on TV one day this that the
other thing we go in the audience and
and John Stewart comes up and talks to
me because I'm just I'm would have been
picked for the price is right let's
before any part of not being being fired
up so yeah that once I got the money
from the prices right I was sort of like
off to the races and it took two years
to track down Bill Gates three tell me
about that transition so we're kind of
now going into interview four and we've
set some context yeah you want a [ __ ]
sailboat you sell a sailboat you got a
couple dollars what's the leap from I've
got a couple bucks from a sailboat -
I've gotta meet Bill Gates what was the
thesis that you were running on at that
point was it that if I can figure out
how the most successful people were you
clearly had a brain that figured out how
to get on prices right were you always
that kind of social engineer that you
said if I can spend a lot of time with
successful people over the course of a
period time I might figure out what
actually works and then I'll do that for
myself later in life it started from a
life crisis I was 18 I was a freshman in
college and I'm spending every day lying
on my dorm room bed staring up at the
ceiling and to understand why it wasn't
that I hated it it was that I in the son
of Jewish immigrants which pretty much
means I came out of the womb my mom
cradle made her arms and then she
stamped MD on my ass and sent me on my
way like different childhood than you
know questions like the doctor track
100% listen this is you know I'm glad
you're here I'm glad we're doing this
podcast because it's gonna create some
clarity when I talk about being grateful
right think about you two talking about
your backgrounds different things yeah
but two things that make me say I'm
grateful for mine because I did have
parent you know think you both parent
situations have ramifications that I
worry about which is either there it's
like a tough scene or it's not a tough
scene but there's an expectation on the
child that doesn't take the child into
consideration the
my mom took me into consideration like
watched me and then decided okay
you'll be an entrepreneur not that she
used that terminology watched my brother
AJ I really changed up the game on my
mom because she looked at my brothers AJ
and said oh you're gonna be a lawyer I
mean you'll be a good student I swooped
in cuz I was older I was like [ __ ]
lawyer [ __ ] as you understand I wasn't
gonna be an entrepreneur but he was kind
of like half I'm just grateful and so
that MD you know a lot of people are
listening right now and they understand
Weezy right they understand being a
minority a female not comment from
nothing that's understandable we do not
talk about in our society the people
that I actually have equal let me say a
now and people can get mad at me just
because I know what depression looks
like we're judging happiness on the
outside we have not started the
conversation unhappiness on the inside
and when we get to the conversation of
happiness on the inside I know the
people in this room some of the people
they know the people that are the most
unhappy on the inside are the ones that
have too much and it is I get it and you
can judge me now I'll see you in 80
years when people talk about you know
privilege they talk about all the right
things white privilege yes male pretty s
gary vaynerchuk's point of view on
privilege the right mindset you want
real privilege get born with good mental
DNA and be in good mental DNA
environment because having nothing or
being stamped that you need to be an
engineer lawyer or doctor from the get
is adversity and it's going to lead to
either really bad [ __ ] or really great
[ __ ] and that my content on a daily
basis is to help somebody who's on the
path of really bad [ __ ] find a curveball
to start the process of being in really
good shape because it's a kissing cousin
you are literally gonna be completely
devastatingly unhappy and have a piece
of [ __ ] life or completely dominate the
Delta is enormous
Alex I apologize so you have a net well
you don't apologize because you actually
teed it up perfectly because your
content is I was 18 years old a freshman
in college the pre-med of pre-meds
but I'm looking at the stack of biology
books feeling like they're stuck in the
life out of me so then I'm wondering
maybe I'm not on my path maybe I'm out
on a path somebody placed Mountain I'm
just rolling
down so now I'm going through this life
crisis I'm watching your videos
literally eighteen years old two months
into college in my study rooms on a
Friday night all my friends are at a
fraternity party I'm up there watching
when you're icky nuts for the first time
and I swear man I will never forget that
night because my dad called me like five
times I didn't answer because for the
first time I was realizing maybe this
isn't my path so now not only do I not
know what I want to do I don't know all
the people I looked up to how they did
it how did Bill Gates sell his first
piece of soft ride of his dorm room when
nobody knew his name had it Spielberg
become the youngest director in
Hollywood history when he's rejected
from film school these are the things
they don't teach you in school so in my
pain and in my confusion I had a very
naive idea of well why don't I just call
up Bill Gates and interview my husband
myself I thought I'll take three months
seven years later just came out
unbelievable yeah Thank You Man thank
you for all that Vice along the way my
play time my pleasure
let's go back around what is the most
interesting thing in culture in the
world going on right now
that doesn't have to do with barstool
like what are you watching like is there
a restaurant that has a $800
cheeseburger are you obsessed this is
I'm gonna preface it what are you
obsessed with right now that you're
watching that's happening out there I've
come to realize oh I'm anthropologists
like I'm started it's amazing who I
think I am now literally I decided this
a week ago the last week I'm like oh
those people that go to the jungle for
four years to study the red beaked
baboon that's me I just do that with
people so I'm always watching that's my
love that's I always find it funny
because I'm gonna interrupt you guys 10
times here and I was like you're not a
listener you're such an [ __ ]
stop interrupting people I'm like man
I'm such a listener it's just I listen
differently I'm watching for cues that's
what I've done my whole life so there's
always things that are catching my
attention right like for example if this
was a year and a half ago I'd be like
this woman cardi B's got my attention
I've never listened to her I didn't
listen to a single cardi B song before I
read over a hundred thousand comments
about cardi B yeah that's weird I've now
realized and I'm articulating it more
because maybe it's gonna help somebody
figure out [ __ ] but that's kind of like
heavy
what about like your what do you obsess
with right now like a new drink a new
t-shirt a new show
your nephews new girlfriend like give me
something here I'm obsessed with going
into nail salons and seeing what they
are watching what is a default show what
is the default show I want to know is it
politics or is it like daytime like
Steve our best ones are either Korean or
Chinese television love it
Korean and Chinese television is
fascinating because it's YouTube it's
young there's a lot of characters there
doing stupid [ __ ] and the energy is all
anything like I don't like it when the
nail salon runs the like cheapo fake
news station right or like the weather
innocuous yes
content but if you go do you like walk
in I just log in to just keep I don't
know yep Oh like cuz it's New York City
so you can there's like six nails on low
the other thing is Irish bars I love
Irish yes so I always walk into like
like I walked over Hima Keeley's yeah
okay you walk in like who's there what's
on the television what are they serving
there's a lot of proper football on
those television proper football yes
there's a lot of actually in the morning
leo
nothing is weird as stalking the nail
salons choice television shows buddies
I'm super into coffee specifically
espresso have a machine at home
is it fancy yeah super fancy but it's
like I got it
I got quite cheap on eBay is repaired
it's sick guys these special machines
are expensive yeah I'm just found out
about this I don't know if people know
about this you spend like $20,000 in
espresso me show ya yeah well I didn't
know this what is the cost do like what
makes it better so it's just all about
like the name on the machine you order
your Nespresso that's just like some
[ __ ] right there like whatever is
Maserati shines like it's all it's like
manual you know you grind the coffee of
expensive grinder the particle size of
the coffee is is uniform
nice yeah I drink a lot of coffee so I
do take pride in knowing like what's
going into it like I used to drink eight
cups of coffee a day and my boy Chris
Baca who is like a nationally ranked
barista he owns this coffee that I
brought for the team or whatever he he
would see me coming you like dude you
drink like eight cups of coffee a day
have you ever tried espresso and I was
like no what's espresso and he's like
well it's like four to six ounces of
coffee caffeine wise but in a one ounce
package so you get all your caffeine you
need but you have a lot less acidic
beverage in your stomach so for me it
just started out with like like hacking
it basically like cool I'll have less of
a stomachache and I'll be just as jacked
up and then I became like enamored with
it and to learn like Oh became like a
wine thing exactly [ __ ] you not when I
was starting to see like going back into
the old wine content because I started
doing like the brown bag stuff I was
like I like this [ __ ] so I started
watching the old [ __ ] yeah and I
realized that like I knew dick about
like the finer things in life and you
know I started doing like food wise or
whatever you know I started doing the
coffee because it's like where is it
from
how is it that it opens up the hole how
is it prepared now if it tastes like
butter toffee like whatever that it's
insane that's what gets you into like
sushi or oysters or it just opens up so
you think it tastes better if you buy it
like I can't it doesn't matter how good
whatever machine I don't have a good
probably part of it but like I have to
buy coffee it tastes better if I buy it
hmm oh that's better and I get yes ten
minutes I can teach you how to make the
best really
okay that's episode of processes Alex I
am obsessed especially the past year
with stand-up comedy okay
oh you're gonna do that aren't you like
I know you do it like are you gonna look
at it I think he knows I know are you
gonna really do it it's like an alter
ego fantasy just like being a rapper I
know I know you well enough to know this
do you think you're gonna do it
yeah I'll [ __ ] around with this yeah I
thought so too you gotta give it your
you have enough I've never said that a
lie by the way I believe all my friends
are bad sound like no I
and I knew that I could get you to say
cuz I knew that you knew you can trick
me I really really think you will and
here's why I know you just enough to
know this
there's too much upside and not enough
downside hmm that's why you're gonna do
it it's a hack and it's funnest [ __ ] man
there's too much upside it's why did the
sneaker deal the reason I did the case
was sneaker deal was it was too much
upside with not enough downside if it
worked and it's kind of like doing its
thing right now and I got to keep
building momentum then it's like wow you
really that's crazy that he pulled that
off
the economics the god forbid the whole
genre goes that album the [ __ ]
Jordans of the whole thing [ __ ] you
Michael Jordan write that whole thing if
it didn't work what funny fodder like
nine years from now we're like I'm being
interviewed like okay look you're really
successful before we start this fireside
chat can we go back to 2017 the [ __ ]
were you thinking about doing a sneaker
too much upside with not enough downside
that's why I think you're gonna do it if
you're watching Seinfeld right now on
comedians in cars getting coffee I think
in 50 years we'll look back and say he
was a [ __ ] philosopher not a comedian
oh I understand I fully think and he's a
craftsman listen I'm a I have a lot of
respect for Seinfeld I wouldn't call
myself a huge Seinfeld fan I will say
this because I adore Hasan Minhaj yeah I
watched that episode because of Hasan
Minhaj uh and I was super disappointed
in Seinfeld inability to it's funny I
cut people off because we don't edit
they film all day they edit really easy
to make it seem like nobody's getting
cut off I thought that was a super
awkward episode and it made me think
that I was surprised that he wasn't
capable of adjusting to the guests like
I felt that the Kate McKinnon which I
also watched it came natural thus it was
great the Hasan Minhaj it didn't come
natural and I thought it was really bad
thoughts I think that your keynotes are
stand-up comedy and I think and I think
with Seinfeld you especially your Q&A
it's that's that's where you get the
most in up yeah when I see it come out
in it yeah and I think with Seinfeld and
Hasan Minhaj that episode it was surface
yeah and it could have gone deep I've
seen other stuff with yeah I'm like the
White House well honesty both for both
I think it was styles make fights right
that's right I love you for give me
something do you know many people never
ever react when I use that analogy
that's a bird it's it's a oh you have to
be an an old-school boxing guy like like
the guys with cigar Bert sugar was the
icon it was too passed away several
years ago like a 1957 Irish bar three
cigars a fights on it's two great
fighters and everyone's bored and and
one guy's gonna look at the other guy
and go
styles make fights that's like my life
philosophy when the hell people walk in
here and quit vaynermedia and tell me
I'm a dick hmm I say in my brain styles
make fights
this kids a great kid vaynermedia's got
great intent styles make fights it
didn't click at this moment at this time
it didn't click they're not a dick
veiners not a bad place styles make
fights and that's what I that's what I
was watching it and six minutes like two
seconds in but six minutes and I'm like
Fox styles make fights sure but Pacquiao
Mayweather mmm that's the most extreme
style seismic fights you know and and
but what's what's funny is like it
depends on who like you know it's just
it styles make fights Micky Ward Arturo
Gatti too solid to below-average
fighters depending on how you want to
argue it but the two of them made magic
over three fights
if literally you you love sports or if
you love theater go Google Arturo Gatti
Micky Ward and watch those three fights
you'll [ __ ] better than the
ridiculousness of a rocky fight and
drama in real life it's actually crazy
and I know a lot of you aren't boxing
fans at UFC Dowd and a lot of you kids
don't like either or whatever or older
might go watch them it's [ __ ] theater
Erica what's happening in sports does a
ton so speaking that we bought a boxing
promoter last October called rough and
rowdy and it is all style makes fights
well this is your pay-per-view ship yeah
amateur fighters I'm so obsessed with
you it's awesome you're so smart so fun
I just want people to know I think
you're smart thank you
I think you're smart too thank you
nobody like I'm blown away by what you
guys have done they're fun economic
people don't get it's really almost like
you know what influencers have done to
like real celebrities I think that's
what you're gonna do to be asked a media
tour set but net net what's amazing why
I'm obsessed with that these tell every
but I don't know what you publicly said
about numbers or not from a success
standpoint really quick cuz I don't
think a lot of people know about yep you
did a pay-per-view on the internet we
did a pay-per-view so we bought a boxing
promoter Dave Portnoy who the founder of
barstool huge visionary single best
promoter I've ever met in my life went
and did a video in 2012 on this weirdo
West Virginia boxing promoter where he
just had guys from West Virginia in a
high school basketball gym beat the [ __ ]
out of each other you know the [ __ ] the
street fights that I I watch I could
sook no content the only thing that
catches me still to this day is to
random people fistfights a train on
Instagram and on YouTube you cannot look
away I love it the most cannot look away
cuz the high that I get from a natural
knockout a one-punch knockout I've not
been able the only the hot sports which
I'm obsessed with here's the thing back
to highs that we mentioned earlier that
get me from zero the high is going from
zero to a thousand a one-punch knockout
a over time scoring goal mmm-hmm playoff
hockey yeah over time scoring goalie
I mean I don't even care about hockey
for a long time now cuz the Rangers won
in 94 sometime you know my son starting
into sports so make him consume
everything a playoff hockey game that is
because it's over in a blank it's over
in a play it's like life it's why I love
life so much over to blink yep
but then there's also like pride and
honor and class and the backstory
[ __ ] you I'm gonna win like it's all of
that so net net we put together this was
crossing event and it's but it's for an
internet consuming era it's 330 fights
3-1 minute rounds it goes very very very
fast so that's my opinion of sports what
is your next one
next Sunday so yeah town Ohio we have
done this is rough and rowdy five so
next on five next Sunday I'm gonna watch
it Tyler get my calendar alive from
Youngstown Ohio which is the birthplace
of boxing in the US it's gonna be
awesome grit city a grit love it we did
a we have a marquee fight between a cop
and a skateboarder and the cop is
awesome guy named Ryan young gave us
full access we rode around with him 24/7
and he got fired and he got Gator the
skateboarder yeah I'm a second I'm a
skateboarder guys so when it got fired
because he's in Barstow Sports is he
looking for a job we were gonna make him
whole for the next two years I love you
so much guys I'm telling you I'm like we
were putting this together alex has been
hitting me up he's like yo I need to
promote my book I'm [ __ ] love the
hustle reason nothing on me off of three
years ago can I get a [ __ ] physical
cosign I appreciate the verbal cosines
so I knew I want to do a pod sessions
because I'm running out of time before
like I got to fit a lot of stuff in next
three weeks so it's like cool time for a
pod sessions and I'm like all right
these two [ __ ] dick faces you should
i rap
look can I drown doubt this show with
that is so gnarly that's just gonna make
this whole thing fun to look back at I'm
super into you okay
breezy what's the best like little flip
you've had like whether it's a book or
something like listen single clip
nothing gets a high from me like a
single micro flip I actually already
heard about you buying out a warehouse
in oh my god I'm talking about one book
one scan or I don't even know what about
a book so I didn't think it would be the
best single item I ever flip no no I
don't want historic so we'll go to that
to in the last 60 days because I assume
you're still practitioner yeah are you
now just a [ __ ] pontificate er no
respect so what have you flipped in the
last 60 70 80 days that was just like a
funny one off I want some random [ __ ]
you're like it's super boring
yeah so mostly books so I got ollie sold
several three hundred dollar books in
the last month or a quarter cool so I
need this know that they're great when
you buy these skins the [ __ ] out of that
so we have the entire canvas on our skin
yeah well they're cheaper now Technol
you caught up but and we have
smartphones so I have the entire
database of Amazon in my phone and then
I scan it with the barcode I cry I don't
need for this cell signal
not only does he have a sense of the
price but he's a sense of the demand
scene or the market yeah now I wanted to
give this to the audience - it's called
sales rank on Amazon so it's the number
that indicates how well something sells
in theirs they're separate for each
category so in books the number one
best-selling book has a sales rank of
one right I'm sure like crushing it's
probably crushing it well maybe on
launch day you know what you got up to
on launch day I'm launching six number
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah so -
actually I think wait Saturday mornings
are you just prowling around yard sale I
don't mean to be nice how'd you do cuz I
actually really really enjoy it like one
of my favorite things is to just look up
completed sales on eBay just go oh
marbles like when like I'm just
basically copy and would move mortals
are worth money more mind-blowing you're
like whoa people collect vintage paper
like it's the minutes and you're like I
saw some last week they was they were
throwing it away like it's like an
affiliate model and that's what I'm do
so or stole basically I think that
that's I know you're not good at
monetizing my audience or anything I
still do my core business like my
business that I run which I've a
business partner with following the pin
then I do the smart one and then I do my
personal brand which makes me a little
bit of money like my youtube video
there's links like if you need a printer
go get that winner he had bigger
economics when he gets paid $100,000 for
one speech than making okay got it
now he's actually going to London to
speak in two weeks he has economics
elsewhere thus isn't monetizing his
violence I got you got it to build the
attention to monetize in the future if
he even sure to smart what's gonna
eventually happen is gonna realize the
admirations a bigger higher than the
money and it's not gonna get yeah and
monetizing the audience which is okay
which is the best that's a yeah because
now I'm like no I and everything because
now you know last year people would hit
me up for sponsored YouTube videos and I
was telling my price and they would not
even yet answer yep and now I tell him
and they pay me
right away yep so if I'd be raising the
price soon good for you what's the best
signal so go 300 ready cuz I need people
here nice cuz I'm upset listen you know
how passionate I am about this yeah what
I don't talk about anything outside my
kind of normal stuff other than a little
bit of co-signing some hip-hop artists
on the rise and a little bit of like
like though and you've seen I've gotten
really hot on like cuz you know I'm
getting a thousand emails that say oh
yoga Gary Vee but I have no money so I
went to the rogas place which is cool
here's the new flip Craigslist free yeah
it's price on that you go and you take
it it's [ __ ] free then you go to face
book marketplace because the thing that
you learn about pregs is free ways he's
as good as books are small Craig's is
freeze bad cuz [ __ ] is big it's like a
[ __ ] chair and [ __ ] cinder block
and like they still don't believe you
though right
system 3 so my thing is not are being on
Amazon eBay which is what I would
recommend for his world and the stuff I
love but on Craigslist the flip is
Amazon Marketplace excuse me Facebook
marketplace you go and pick up a [ __ ]
hammock and then you list it for 30 on
Facebook and you sell it in [ __ ] five
minutes the reason so many people are
selling on five minutes is it's a supply
and demand game yeah Facebook
marketplace is still not saturated but
Facebook is so at scale the people are
seeing [ __ ]
yes it's clockwork there's so much free
stuff that like for example I we moved
to an apartment we moved to a condo from
our house okay and we had a trampoline
at our house well we can't have a
trampoline at the condo so I tried to
sell it for months before we move yeah
no one bought it so I gave it away for
free the day before we moved three
trampoline that I only had for three
months 18 foot traveling for pry 350
bucks at least and they got it for free
and you could easily sell that so it's
like you have to wait it out you have to
use bad keywords you have to put it on a
different marketplace treadmills people
January people are I'm gonna get fit
they buy treadmill to buy freaking
workout machines whatever they're called
and then they do it for like a month and
Marco dusty yeah then it's from on the
free section cuz no one's gonna buy a
treadmill people buy a brand new trip
you can't be creating QVC why haven't
you done that
listen I've got to listen why haven't I
done that is like the story of my life
what do you want I can do it I'm
crippled by opportunity that like I
could do everything what I think I'm
doing right now and you might remember
this from the rant and like past
backstage I'm building a machine to let
me do everything I'm gonna do [ __ ]
everything yeah
I'm just painting machine that's 72
years old I'm gonna be like yep QVC then
why do t-shirt company like new field
look fine
like I'm just building a [ __ ] yes I'm
gonna fight stripes like
you understand Vader's gonna do
everything yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] take
ownership everything all of it totally
happily and everyone's gonna be happy
for me yep what's the so this 25 cents
to 300 bucks here's why I'm very
passionate about this reezy the most
important there's all the people that
you and I think about when we talk about
this subject matter that can literally
go from being miserable making 78,000
being the regional manager of four
restaurants to making 109 flippin Star
Trek memorabilia because they love it I
mean oh that's real which is crazy
I'm actually really focusing on
something very narrow lately with my
whole I've got no money none right and a
hundred bucks is game-changing like
literally the I mean Tyler you're the
one that knows this like oh and some of
my social media the amount of DMS this
stuff is emotional like making an extra
hundred bucks and mike is like and you
know this you come from that dirt so so
I'm just like man [ __ ] Craigslist
free if you're just raw and hungry even
if you're not wrong hungry even if you
want to just move out of your apartment
like if you don't give a [ __ ] about what
people it's the promise people give a
[ __ ] away you you know why I'm crazy I'm
now at where I'm at and I'm rolling up
to garage sales and people like Gary Vee
and I'm still in garage sale know and
I'm like yo you want a quarter for that
yeah and like when you really don't give
a [ __ ] about what people think
you know like I'm pulling up and like
like it looks like a Range Rover I don't
know how expensive but I don't even know
how much my cars are like I'm not a like
like a car that I'm sure is probably
some money and like negotiating with
people like yo [ __ ] it was I'm like 25
cents [ __ ] when you don't care
about what the biggest reason somebody
broke his [ __ ] is not listening to my
advice is they care about what other
people think they're embarrassed to go
pick something up and carry a
here on the bus cuz they have no money
cuz they're worried somebody's gonna
look at them
I want people judging me I want the chip
on my shoulder
anyway 25 cents to 300 what is that good
we'll scan everything and one of them's
300 yeah are they usually are they
usually college books so the
best-selling books are not are
nonfiction mostly textbooks are the sure
it's a huge scam so we could you've been
to college you know that hurts you know
it's like yeah you I know you do heavy
garage excuse me heavy goodwill that
kind of stuff Fred do you ever garage
sale I used to a lot okay so now I know
why it's less efficient than goodwill
and other things and church sales and
book sales I get that take me back to
garage sale day right did you ever hit a
mother lode where you literally rolled
up on like a professor or like a former
college admin and there was like 88
texts what do you say Jay my brother
right right we have the story of we were
hardcore we were so right about video
games like I love them people like oh
you're just I just posted this article
about why I'm going all-in on Twitch and
my whole social mean is like oh I beat
Gary Venus something you're so late you
suck and I'm laughing I'm like mother
[ __ ] I was buying video games in 2000
like cartridges because I thought there
would be memorabilia in 2030 when you
were like [ __ ] - dick like I'm late
I'm just entering when I enter so we
were hardcore video games we were so
right we just have like a hundred
Contras they were five back in the day
they're like 45 now like we nailed it
right right if my dad didn't throw them
all away you out of spite and anger of
us holding him there it would have been
like an incredible ROI what's really
interesting to me is we did have that
one day that we dreamed of he wrote we
rolled up on a Friday afternoon which is
big again to an old man that was 70
which again never has video games right
but somehow it must been his grandkids
stuff
AJ finds a box with unlimited rare RPG
games like ninja gaiden trilogy and
[ __ ] Megaman this in fact literally
AJ bought for $10 40 games that was
worth almost three four thousand dollars
did you ever have that in the textbook
game I rolled up at a Christian school
and they were
completely closing down or they were
selling everything I'm assuming they
were closing how'd you find that was
that Craigslist the internet or do were
you driving and saw a big sign no you
knew it was I use the app called yard
sale Treasury like I don't remember cuz
I was looking to a different one but he
roll off it wasn't as big of the lick as
it could have been because it was an
elementary school elementary school
textbooks are not know it's rare that
the ones like 30 bucks I got like 500
books and you know like thirty dollar
books I got like twenty copies of it you
know so they weren't like ten how much
in these other books I paid like a
quarter a book or something but they
were it wasn't even about the money they
were just happy that I took all the
books because people were taking the
together so people taking course mature
they're like what are we gonna do with
all these yes I was like I'll take them
and so what gift do did you have to go
do you have a big enough vehicle you had
packed him in the Subaru multiple trips
you're able yeah yeah trips yeah let me
tell you about one of mine back to paper
which I learned along the way was great
too
this is a great story that I don't think
I've ever told I was going to a Wine
Library business meeting in H I was in
high school two thousand five in two
thousand three or four like a 230 like
go to this restaurant taste wine buy for
the store
yeah fine uh
this story's too good I don't come new
jersey to [ __ ] you know Sarah nod to
tastes like thirteen Rieslings to buy
one for Wine Library and I see and I'm a
little hair and I mean like Erica has to
go in five minutes hair early right and
it's a garage sale today Friday and
Fridays are gangster because the a lot
of like the the scale comes on samplers
still out or does that work and I'm like
[ __ ] I'm going I find one of these weird
ones where I was I said I can't go and
then at the last second kind of like had
to go I like went past the turn and
almost got like into an accident and I
roll up I walk in and I see an old
huckleberry what's that hanna-barbera
character Huck I don't know the bluish
dog yes yeah sorry Finn yes so sorry
hound
around so I saw 1978 Knickerbocker
Huckleberry Hound nice condition of my
boom got a dollar good that's like
thirty I'm already pumped right I go in
the basement and I see [ __ ] boxes and
I mean 80 boxes and i wole up into it
and it is
playbills from broadway at a scale that
you couldn't believe from the 40s to the
80s Wow
so I go into the state sale so I'm like
I'm gonna get [ __ ] because you know
state sales because they're more
expensive I go how much they're like
well 50 cents apiece I'm like how much
do you want for all of this to go all of
it I and I know no value I'm not doing
I'm a purist I don't look [ __ ] up I
still like jerk myself around if I was
doing filter I look up everything but
I'm still and back then you couldn't
look up this way no smartphones we used
to have to do it on the [ __ ] gut they
go well what about 120 and I'm like what
about 20 and I'm like 20 like I kind of
tried to do something obi-wan Kenobi
[ __ ] like 20 they're like 13 it's yours
I take it I buy it I did have a cell
phone
yeah I had a cell phone yes I called
that's khabar that was his name Dave
Barna I called Dave barn I'm like yo I'm
sick or I [ __ ] and drove home to AJ
to take him out of high school to look
up all the [ __ ] nonetheless we made like
a gajillion and there was like 1940
baseball guides there was the [ __ ]
original Pinocchio [ __ ] movie they
like and they're like Betty Davis and
like [ __ ] Judy Garland like they were
like 30 40 50 25 cents for 300 I need
people to understand who are listening
ray I'll get a [ __ ] scanner like how
much were these scanners now like a
hundred hundred fifty bucks refurbished
300 brand-new all right Tyler so we do
we're gonna do something we're easy
we're gonna do a day like we're gonna do
a day I'm just gonna give out like
[ __ ] 50 of them just gonna pick a day
in September when we get back just
random and we're gonna do some sort of
funny he's gonna tweet something cryptic
and I'm gonna see who replies and just
[ __ ] hit him hard giving away [ __ ]
scanners because this would be this
literally be you know you if this will
be me giving people a fishing pole and
then [ __ ] eat Erica you got about
in two minutes give me something good
what do you want to talk about what are
you thinking about what do you think
about when you hear this do you like
garage saleing I love garage sales
what's your garage sale game alright I
used to buy a lot of clothes on eBay and
I like because you were like super cool
like retro vintage retro vintage and
cheap like retro vintage and cheap which
is a good combination yeah and then that
became cool you were a head that became
cool but then it became not cool
whatever but it's like hard to part with
it but what do I like in garage sales I
just like what people have seen that
[ __ ] yeah what is going on in your life
like how'd you get here who are you what
are you about like what are you
collecting how messy are you are you a
hoarder like I love the psychology we
hope they're hoarders yeah hoarders are
great but it's funny like I just cleaned
out our garage and like put a bunch of
[ __ ] in a dumpster and I'm like I had we
have this like lovely Spanish weirdos
they're located no but I've done it
before
from it you know it's funny when I agree
I would do it right now I'll [ __ ] go
in a dumpster
yeah or I'm sound weird I'm just gonna
[ __ ] dumb great dirty is yeah dirt I
mean it's a reward of it my remember I
can't lie grew up and was born in
Colorado no money and my parents like
furnished our house from the dump like
the dump was like could you imagine I
was buried at the dump that's really
good is behind shopping malls because I
was just thinking could you imagine like
like if I'd like cuz I'm now getting
hyped and I might get bored late August
on my vacation could you imagine super
in Long Island somebody driving into a
shopping center like do the groceries
and I my head pops out of a dumpster and
they're like was that Gary be like
that's like how much videos there Alex
how's your book doing it's doing great
okay I'm gonna come out just about a
month ago okay
tell the truth because this is what I
love about unison why I wanted you on
the show did it do as well in week one
as you thought it was gonna do not what
you hoped like straight unemotional like
my kids not the cutest all the time talk
you have a lot of relationships I'm
fascinated by when somebody plays life
the way you do which is try to do the
right thing
have my own ambitions pay forward to
build relationships I think the thing
that is always fascinating about a kid
or not a kids first book especially when
they're smart and know how to ask for a
right hook is who comes through and who
doesn't you must have been so fascinated
in your first month or two of the people
in your mind you're like oh that
socialite girl is gonna put me on and is
definitely gonna do the selfie picture
because I've done nine great things for
her and then she didn't or or when
somebody came through and bought a
hundred and did something rad that you
only met once tell everybody who's
listening the fascination of that ten
years of being on the game seven years
of meaning game and then writing a book
and going in for those right hooks and
who came through and who didn't and why
and how it did so you're right most
fascinating thing but you I don't you
don't remember this at all but when I
was nineteen you gave me three pieces of
a book advice and one of them was bring
your expectations to zero and I remember
I was like that makes no sense
and as I was gearing up this past year I
was like if I don't do that I'm gonna be
[ __ ] depressed
I am super happy man dude I could not be
here and I would still love you 100%
because expertise from zero brother
that's what I do all the time you
reprogram me when I was 19 you don't
know that though what's amazing about
that is for me the thing about that is
that is why I'm happy hmm
literally everybody's unhappy because
they have expectations from something
the government humans in general their
mother their best friends the person
they did all these things for you many
[ __ ] running around right now do [ __ ]
with some agenda on the back end and
when that person doesn't come through
for them they're mad at the person but
they were the piece of [ __ ] for trying
to set up the ask people set up the ask
for me all day long I see it all day
long all day long
they're the [ __ ] I'm so glad you
[ __ ] took that advice and you're
right that is why you're happy huh week
one it was crazy because I had I had a
goal for sales the week before I was
like 40% there so you were nervous
terrifying I was like back against the
wall like trying to close deal this is
number come from because it's always
arbitrary um the it it all came
throughout that week
no no uh just talking to people you know
they say like thirty thirty thousand
gets you this ten thousand gets you this
so I was your number
it's ten you all should shoot II for ten
week one I love you for that cuz that to
me knowing you from afar and obviously
intimately and your early days and
things that nature that's a very
realistic number I've uh I've you
support you pleasantly just surprised me
and that doesn't happen to me often
Thank You Man I'm proud of you man
that's really good thank you okay so you
have four thousand you're like [ __ ] dude
Pete my publisher is printing five
thousand copies but I'm like my goal is
10,000 you know and at the last second
they had to do three reprints yeah I hit
ten thousand week one that's awesome and
I wa dude I know you do that like in a
day before the book is out much you're
waiting you're ten years into the Gator
and horse dude dude I'm super proud of
you in the ten thousand we're gonna do
another book right now it's a it's a
month in okay I'm a month in and the
most surprising thing man
not just that okay look there's people
who didn't give up hook it up the way I
thought I hoped
I hope they would hook it right Emily
and I always there's hope and there's
expectation and I hope yes is that
everybody I'm like yo they buy 80,000
pairs of sneakers I hit him up I'm like
yo let's go hard he's on yo bro I don't
I'm not you know because I'm thing about
the flip game and everything I hit him
up because I'm like he's really that and
he's like yo like like I can't buy
[ __ ] a thousand your for a hundred
and your sticks I'm like bet I get it
like I I never like there's always hope
and act like the reason I wrote Jab Jab
Jab right hook it's so important give
give give and then ask not take or
expect I'm super thrilled to ask but
when the answer is no or I can't
I'm like you know where i weirdly go
compassion
it was crazy when we have that exchange
I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ] dude like
that's probably why you're on think
about that
the know for the sneaker to like two
months it goes like why did you ask me
to buy a thousand pairs I don't even
remember dude you know what happens I go
on planes and I you know how it actually
happens it's crazy gonna love this I
know it's DM and I hit the a button and
whoever shows
I just go freestyle like literally I
probably hit are on [ __ ] Instagram
direct message knew I had seven minutes
to [ __ ] throw right hooks hit are
your [ __ ] glasses [ __ ] cartoon
came up I hit it and I'm like yo by a
thousand I don't know I I think you're
making 40 million a year on [ __ ]
selling books right you don't know and
the cool thing is when you don't expect
and your intent is pure you don't get
come it doesn't get convoluted when you
say Universal I remember the energy I
don't remember verbatim I remember the
energy of like yo Dawg listen bro I've
already I supported you last thing like
I got I don't have it like that I'm
doing my thing over there and I remember
going to like bet totally like and where
my there you responded in like 0.2
seconds because I appreciate the honesty
some people like I got you and they
don't come through - I'm like okay yeah
like I so think you're gonna like you
didn't miss the ultimate compliment I
think you're gonna end up in such a
crazy place if you can stay disciplined
that I'm probably thinking you're like
it's like me I have way less money than
people think
way less because I'm betting all-in if I
started my mastermind tomorrow I'd make
100 million a year so I understood it I
had empathy and it probably in the last
18 months that you've been trying to get
here it's you say no nothing for the
sneakers is why you're sitting here
think about the [ __ ] that's hilarious
and think about the brain [ __ ] that is
if that is not the lesson of this
[ __ ] episode
it's empathy on empathy on empathy non
expectation the reasoner smile and left
and right is the there's people that
probably really let you down on your
hope like when I said that right now two
or three faces flashed in front of your
head but when you don't have
expectations you can get over it you
doesn't mean you're not like to your
homies like that [ __ ] remember I
[ __ ] introduce them to the hottest
girl he ever hooked up with like I know
like there's thing like said no to me
that I [ __ ] put onto an investment
that they made 10 million dollars on and
they couldn't buy 100 of my books they
made 10 milli there's a dude right now
running around he knows who he is if
he's listening and here's the best part
I got love for him yeah clearly at that
moment who the [ __ ] knows what's going
on I'm not judging but hope and
expectations two different things and
when you learn how to separate that [ __ ]
you get
real happy real fast yeah I hope hope
for the best expect for the worst right
% and you and your always have have
empathy right empathise what got you
here I'm like okay cool we need to put
him on the next spot like see cuz close
you know like it's cool like you know
which is why I really resonate with you
being an immigrant I'm not an immigrant
I grew up with immigrants cuz I grew up
so poor you know I get up in the barrio
and I never had anything to lose my
parents neglected me so I learned how to
ask and not give a [ __ ] because of what
did that blues you know they hate to
speak up or you're not gonna listen
that's how if you when you got something
right and then what let's stay here for
a second right Brides really cute when
you have something when you no food or
shelter that's why you know I make this
comment a lot I'm like I would not judge
somebody who's got nothing and his
homeless stealing fruit from a basket I
don't know what else to tell you I I
can't get over it like that is my truth
belief like I get it you actually said
that you would steal food for your kids
thank you cuz I would because I'm
telling you that really I would I would
and I would keep score and if my
circumstances changed I'd roll up on the
[ __ ] you know go day got nine years
later be like yo here's 83 bucks and you
guys were like what am I gonna stole 83
dollars worth of [ __ ] three years
actually sold 72 that's inflation got
you see yeah like I believe in the macro
I think it's why I'm not scared of
making mistakes right like the reason I
live so in the open is cuz I don't fear
I don't fear because if I make a mistake
which I intend on doing cuz I'm a human
I'm gonna own that [ __ ] and as long as
it's not [ __ ] murder or a stiff thumb
that's some [ __ ] serious as [ __ ] I'll
be able to get over it yes you'll be
disappointed me I'm disappointed myself
more than you'll ever be disappointed me
if I do something who knows what can
happen in life people like you're so
lucky I'm like until tomorrow when my
kids die in a [ __ ] car accident then
am i lucky in life why are we judging
LeBron so lucky what if his [ __ ] wife
and kids going into their new home in LA
right now moving get hit by a bus then
they die forever is LeBron [ __ ] lucky
[ __ ] you stop judging right you
eliminate judgment you will [ __ ] live
[ __ ] judgment is the poison of a
society right now so much judgment you
don't know what's going on somebody's
home definitely
I think that by Allah's book by the way
let's get me 10,000 tomorrow link that
[ __ ] the [ __ ] let's really [ __ ]
humble him and make him realize how much
better I really am in him that one right
hook in my one podcast late into the
episode with a right hook sells more
than his whole [ __ ] life tried to
sell by his [ __ ] book I guarantee
it's good I will never read it but I
never give people DAPs
but this guy is a good kid I like the
way he's doing it do you do audio
version oh yeah I recorded it too you
recorded herself good job I absolutely
hate it when people don't read their own
audio book it's fine it was it was
actually the most fun part of the whole
process last thing you want everybody
know cuz we got to bounce together time
should do I gotta see my family Merida
thanks for having us
bye rough and rowdy next Sunday night
how much is it it is right now $15.99 oh
how do you do Andy nine night off oh
that's how you do it we did an early
bird special or a bunch of stuff that
you've got a whole season for $6.99 cuz
we didn't know oh that's [ __ ] amazing
so fun good for them yeah you know
that's what I do by the way did you do
that
are you gonna do a book you think like
an official book at some point yeah I'm
working on it so I do the best thing
when I sell sneakers or books I come up
with these secret packages totally and
everybody like shits on me like who
wants the [ __ ] on me and I laugh because
I always know that like in Tyler's for
the laughing right now so cool by 10
sneakers I'll probably do one more
surprise for sneakers by 10 sneakers a
thousand bucks by 10 sneakers send me a
receipt I'm gonna I'm gonna get you by
the end of year you don't know what's
gonna happen I laugh because the level
of work we put into giving people
something that's worth more yep then
what they bought for a thousand is like
my obsession I love the sanic game of it
it's off right when you did the preview
and it was $6.99 people don't know we're
gonna get that people are like you're
such an idiot people are stealing from
you and I'm like you know I hope they
still of course what do you have to say
first off Gary is obviously the goat
like if you don't like consume his
content at least check it out I
recommend everybody to read crush it cuz
it thoroughly changed my life and second
is crazy that that book was written in
2008 came out no no yeah like how right
historically that book is so it's insane
it's the blueprint you don't need like
just read crush it that's it you don't
need to read the other books
you watch anything just read crush it
and if you you know if you're not
succeeding and whatever you want to do
after that like it's your own fault but
other than that if you're not happy with
your nine-to-five go to resi TV and hit
subscribe
Pellatt resi TV ar e easy Y TV Alex I
was actually thinking about this in the
elevator coming up yes I'm playing
around this idea you this is the thing I
think you give so much great advice to
so many people you don't remember what
you've told me I think over the past six
years I can write a [ __ ] like five
page white paper on all the crazy things
that you told me do it I'll share it
you'll get look I'll get love that's
done do I love that man do it listen one
thing that you know I don't you know
everyone's busy but so I don't think
this is necessarily hit your three
radars but over the last week or two I'm
starting to really get serious about my
throwback Thursday [ __ ] and is now I'm
in the game now am I now I could put up
videos in two thousand eight and nine
yeah and we've it's been really great
for a couple reasons one for all the
kids out there when they look at it
they're like yo like wait Gary he's been
making videos for ten years I just found
out about him three weeks ago he just
got popular it's like oh [ __ ] this is
step number two it's I'm saying [ __ ]
tried-and-true like my message is not
gonna change
and so like cool me and I'd love that
that's dude it's been working since I
was 18 I chased you down at South by
Southwest you have no idea like dude 18
and all these kids watching this like in
five years they'll be coming on and like
showing you how paid off it's very few
brands like that that's right very few
people like that oh yeah I know that to
be true I knew I knew from the moment
where I knew from the moment that I
watched anything I was like dude this
dude is legit realest [ __ ] he actually
wants to help people like from your
heart like I don't know I wanna buy it
it's just like in my head like just like
a feeling and I was like I was like this
guy is like doing really similar to me
like I believe a zeal I believe you
because I seem like hustler but stamina
that's certain that's yes yeah you know
it's fun I'm looking at all three of you
and I remember more than you might even
think like I think back to our meetings
like like the business meetings
backstage and stuff like that's you know
what I love I love the truth yeah
that's probably the way it's you know
like like like there's so many different
settings in public in one-on-ones so
different it's so much communication on
DMS like business meetings when nobody
was looking like you know like actually
we would probably spend most of our time
together in that one way or do your
period when I was doing nothing yeah
when I was really deep into Vayner when
I wasn't doing wine it or other and I
wasn't doing my floor yes yeah remember
the one a.m. the cafe meeting the 1 a.m.
1 a.m. Mick cafe mccafé keep talking I
was 19 years old and I go do my biggest
dream was to shadow you for a day yep it
wasn't able to work out because of David
like HR things are happening that day
yep and you made it up to me by meeting
me at 1:00 a.m. at the Nick cafe next to
the old Vayner office and when I told
that to people they thought I was
[ __ ] with them I was like he actually
did it you know what's interesting about
that in the fact of not remembering it
so easily it's what I want everybody do
like just do the right thing like yeah
when I hear that and I think to myself
like I can see like I can be outside
myself be like oh that's cool the fact
that it's not something that I want to
tell people or I think it's cool it
means that it's just my being yeah and
that's just they just do so much right
[ __ ] that you can't even remember you're
right [ __ ]
people like right a thousand dollar
check to the you know to charity and
then they [ __ ] promote it for the
rest of their lives like just do the
right thing so much it's normal that
it's normal thank you guys love you
thank you man thanks Gary